Hey,
deliberately developmental organization
is first of all a mouthful.
So we call it a Ddo for short.
And uh,
it's sort of an answer to the question.
If an organization's so valued
developing the capabilities of its
people that would want to create a
culture that could immersively gather
every member of that culture into an
ongoing developmental,
personal kind of learning journey,
what would that,
uh,
culture look like?
What would such an organization look
lark?
And,
uh,
that's what we set out to discover and
you know,
in the process,
uh,
what we learned is that in the ordinary
organization,
most people are doing a second job that
nobody's paying them for.
That second job has to do with looking
good,
hiding their weaknesses,
uh,
covering their inadequacies,
managing other people's favorable
impressions of them.
And you can say that's a human nature.
But,
uh,
it also turns out to be incredibly
costly in ways that we don't think
enough about.
If I keep hiding my weaknesses,
the likelihood that I'm going to
overcome them,
uh,
shrinks to near zero.
And,
uh,
the organization has to keep,
essentially,
I'm paying for the consequences of my
limitations.
And,
uh,
they're paying me a full time salary for
part time work.
So imagine an organization where people
would feel safe enough that they would,
uh,
they would kind of consider they were
hired not because anybody thought they
were perfect,
but because people thought they were
good and that they could learn and uh,
that one of their jobs there,
you know,
is uh,
to learn and uh,
where you get actually supported for,
you know,
revealing your mistakes.
And you could say the kind of,
there's kind of an entrepreneurial
stance toward people development.
You know,
the watchword of entrepreneurial ism is
not to avoid failure,
but to fail frequently at to fail fast
and to fail forward.
So imagine a culture where people were
encouraged to do that so that they
would,
I keep learning and getting better.
And then you would be imagining a Ddo,
a deliberately developmental
organization.
I think another really important feature
of these cultures that anyone would
quickly notice if you spent a little
time in them is a kind of transparency,
a way in which,
um,
people,
and often the way they'll say it is,
I am who I am at work.
Um,
I'm,
in other words,
they're not living a divided life.
This is what we mean by this notion that
an ordinary organizations,
we're all doing a second job.
We're trying to look good.
We're always trying to kind of be at our
best,
uh,
in these organizations.
Uh,
that quickly gets seen as a way of
essentially avoiding one of the most
precious and valuable things that the
culture has to offer you,
which is the opportunity to just be the
same person at work that you are when
you're not at work.
And that means,
you know,
the good,
the bad,
and what you might think is the ugly.
Bridgewater talks about this as a
radical transparency and uh,
that means that,
you know,
in the ordinary,
ordinary organization,
everybody agrees it's unprofessional to
talk critically about people behind
their backs and everybody participates
in it.
And some of you listening right now are
thinking,
I don't do that.
Okay.
You may not be a speaker,
but I bet you've been a listener to such
communications and you didn't say to the
other person,
I think it's unprofessional and wrong
for you to be talking about Ralph to be
behind his back.
So one way or the other passively or
actively,
we have all participated in what we know
to be unprofessional behavior
in bridgewater.
There is no back to be behind.
Why?
Uh,
because hold on to your hats.
In every office and in every meeting
room,
there's tape recording equipment and
every conversation is being tape
recorded.
Not in a creepy NSA a kind of way.
But if I'm having a conversation,
if,
if you report to me and I'm having a
conversation with you,
I haven't had the conversation about you
with my boss and you're not in the room.
So I've now been talking about you.
You don't have to fair through a 400
tapes and see if somebody mentioned your
name.
I have an obligation,
send you an email and let you know you
were discussed.
You know,
in this meeting,
you know,
at such and such a time on such and such
a day.
Feel free if you want to listen to the
tape.
So there's absolutely,
I know it drives people,
uh,
you know,
people get very struck,
by this.
But,
uh,
you know,
it's just one of a number of features
that quickly give you the sense we're
talking about a whole different way of
being at work.
Yeah.